Hamlet is a play written in about 1600
by William Shakespeare and is one of the
most popular and influential stories
ever Hamlet is set in Denmark at a time
when Norway is about to attack and some
dodgy stuff is happening in the royal
castle of Elsinore Prince Hamlet is the
son of King Hamlet and Queen Gertrude at
the start of the play King Hamlet has
died and the King's brother Claudius has
married Gertrude and taken over as king
Prince Hamlet is very upset by all this
moping around saying he wants to die and
that everything sucks he's especially
angry that Gertrude married Claudius so
soon after the King's death so Claudius
and Gertrude are concerned by Hamlet's
behavior they tried to cheer Hamlet up
and when that doesn't work they get a
couple of his old friends Rosencrantz
and Guildenstern to spy on him though
Hamlet sees through the deception then a
ghost appears to Prince Hamlet claiming
to be his dead father King Hamlet's
ghost says that he was murdered by
Claudius with poison and demands that
Prince Hamlet avenge him by killing
Claudius Hamlet isn't entirely sure that
the ghost really is his dead father but
he agrees to kill Claudius he tells his
friends for ratio and Marcellus that he
will act as though he's mad
to prevent drawing suspicion Hamlet
meets with Ophelia who he has a romantic
relationship with Hamlet act crazy and
awful to her telling her he never loved
her and to get to a nunnery Afilias
father Polonius says he thinks Hamlet is
mad with love though earlier he was
saying that Hamlet doesn't love her at
all so Hamlet has a plan to work out for
sure whether Claudius killed King Hamlet
he gets a group of actors to perform a
play in which a king is murdered with
poison
Claudius leaves the room in the middle
of the play which Hamlet sees as proof
that his uncle killed his father later
Hamlet comes across Claudius wrestling
with his guilt in prayer
Hamlet almost kills Claudius there and
then but he decides not to saying that
Claudius might go to heaven if he's
killed while praying
so then Hamlet is talking with his
mother Gertrude when he hears a noise
behind a tapestry in the room he thinks
it's Claudius so he stabs the tapestry
but out Falls Polonius who was spying on
the conversation having killed Polonius
Hamlet borates his mother a bit more
telling her not to have sex with
Claudius until the ghost of King Hamlet
pops up again and tells his on to stop
mucking around and kill Claudius already
Claudius is not feeling terribly safe at
this point so he sends Hamlet with
Rosencrantz and Guildenstern to England
with a letter to the king of England
saying to kill Hamlet Hamlet finds the
letter and changes it so it says to kill
Rosencrantz and Guildenstern instead
meanwhile a philia has gone mad from the
death of her dad and her rejection by
Hamlet and her brother Laertes
Polonius's other child has returned from
France furious he and Claudius make a
plan of their own they'll challenge
Hamlet to a fencing match but Laertes
will have a poisoned sword and Claudius
will offer Hamlet poisoned wine so
Hamlet comes home to Denmark talks with
the gravedigger contemplates death and
finds out that Ophelia has drowned
apparently in a suicidal fit of madness
he has a fistfight with Laertes over who
loved Ophelia more and then the fencing
match begins
Laertes cuts Hamlet with his poisoned
sword then they accidentally switched
swords and Hamlet cuts Flaherty's with
the poisoned sword
Gertrude drinks the poisoned wine
seemingly unknowingly and Hamlet finally
kills Claudius so almost everyone dies
leaving only Horatio to tell the tale to
Fortinbras a norwegian prince who turns
up at the end to take over the danish
throne
so that's Hamlet there are lots of
interesting questions to be asked about
why the characters do what they do
like what's motivating Hamlet what
exactly is he so upset about and why
does it take him so long to do anything
is Hamlet really pretending to be mad or
does he actually go a bit crazy what
about his relationship with Ophelia did
Hamlet ever love her and what's going on
with Gertrude how much does she know
there's lots of stuff going on in Hamlet
about justice and identity and action
and uncertainty and power and gender and
that's part of why Hamlet is so popular
four hundred years after it was written
it's also full of really cool lines
really poetic stuff and funny stuff you
can easily read it online if you want to
check it out anyway thanks for watching
let me know if you'd like to see more
summaries like this you can support this
channel by subscribing and following on
Facebook and Twitter
you